hello and welcome to the lobby
gamespot's weekly hang out every Tuesday
a2 p.m. pacific right here on gamespot
com Justin hey walls was that really
necessary cover but I'm do my intro how
you do it the electronic triple is on in
two weeks time this day two weeks we
will know all of the e3 secrets but
today on the show we're going to talk
about the ones we know about and the
ones we don't i'm joined by Justin hey
what peter brian alexa ray korea we are
talking nintendo first up this time two
weeks time will already have had their
digital event and there'll be in the
middle of their treehouse with a sort of
pepper revenues and whatnot but there's
a bunch of news we're expecting and a
bunch of news we're not expecting
nintendo is really great at keeping
those secrets but they always have
something they always have something
that's going to be super exciting that
not even out any of us know about hmm
let's talk hardware first of all so
we're kind of in this weird situation
where that we use not doing too great
and the slow got a buncha games coming
out vanished and the NX is get a lot of
chat about this week people are just
rumors out that it's going to be an
android based machine Justin get us a
little bit up to speed on where we're
talking with work with the concepts what
are we gonna see at the NX this year
well so we're not going to see anything
of the NX ed3 they've already said that
and that's not surprising like I don't
expect anything to come out of this
until 2017 maybe like super late 2016
this is potentially an e3 reveal for
next year the NX is going to be what
their next system is what that entails
exactly is this going to be the thing
that unifies all of their consoles is
this going to be the handheld plus the
the system that you plug into your TV in
that sense android would kind of make
sense but at the same time nintendo has
shied away from from android type
platform so i don't know that that
necessarily there's any truth to that
rumor but it's not necessarily something
that they've discounted as an operating
system well they did actually like some
point about this morning to me i just
looked it up and yeah nintendo said nope
a chance russell very good at lying in
addition to great save tonight that was
a nick a report they've denied all of
them and behalf of most of them have
sure come true the same thing with like
the bigger 3d ass in the new 3ds so i
don't know i wouldn't discount that yet
yeah i mean it would make sense but I
think you'll areas were even talking
about the NX and that the only reason
nintendo announced it was because
they've been doing piss-poor you have
the past couple years when it comes to
you know making an impact on the market
so a better way to get in
happy again by saying don't worry we've
got more you know coming down the road
well the Wii U is definitely had a
better trajectory this year then any of
its previous like since launch and the
30s has always been a really strong I
mean it had one month where it outsold
the ps4 recently like the three es is
their printing money machine the Wii U
is is staying staying in the race like
it definitely has not fallen off and I
think there's some really fun really
interesting games that and we're gonna
hear about the mini 3 like a reason to
own wii u i mean you hear that a lot in
the office where people like whoa i've
been waiting for zelda I've been waiting
for x game to get it and there's
potential even though we're not going to
hear about so this year and we're not
gonna hear about the NX we might hear
about that game that's like well maybe I
should get away you just to play along
with everybody else so they've said no
Zelda game play as a three this year
which will probably work a lot of people
but there are some other games there
that we are going to be able to look
forward to first of all though stepping
away from hardware they're not quite
into the world of software what amiibo
[ __ ] do you expect to see Eddie free
because all I keep hearing about is amia
bows and how you can't buy them just
like 30 more amoebas I know there are no
they're introducing the cards with the
Animal Crossing game for the 3ds so now
you have a meebo cards then we have
amiibo figures I don't know we're
probably going to get like another three
waves of amoeba figures that will just
write everyone insane when there's the
new pokemon Dungeon Keeper game is
subtitle that's just like because you
basically your Pokemon I think your
Pikachu by default you roam around with
another Pokemon as your sidekick every
Pokemon is supposed to be in that game
but we don't know exactly how all that
sidekick system works no why not tied to
any buzzer 700 oh that's the thing
that's missing like smash brothers has
that 49 character roster all of them are
gonna have an amiibo yeah dude we're
getting we got the chibi Robo amigo
that's so adorable I want one so much
and Yoshi's woolly yarn like the thing
that will keep you going back to those
amigos oh they're different this one's
made of yarn what's gonna bring in the
next wave its Pokemon yeah and the
pokemon card game is so successful
before people are already trained like
buy packs for that yep so what better
way for Nintendo you get that many
characters out there in one fell swoop
and and with because there are so many I
would assume that at least some portion
of those have to be cards they're not
going to be yeah 700 physical Pokemon
and evil he's gone yeah people got
i knowi broke let's talk about games
star fox first of all hopefully gonna
see some this year Justin you saw behind
closed doors last year I did Star Fox
looked really it was a lot of fun last
year I mean we saw very little of it was
basically a tech demo like here is
piloting the ship with your gamepad and
it worked really well like it's it's fun
like I don't know what we're gonna see
gameplay wise and it was interesting
about it was that they had multiple
games tied to it so I think Alexi you
were saying earlier there was like the
giant robot demo and the resurrection
robot in project guard guard guard yeah
and it's the implication when we played
them is that these could be a part of
the Star Fox universe so it's not only
are you in ship combat and flying
through levels but you also have maybe
areas where you're going to be flying
through a city and you have to do some
kind of objective there or maybe where
you get into a giant robot suit and
fight against another creature but there
I mean there's also the possibility that
these could be standalone titles on
their own because they were just kind of
fun minigames and most level editors
come with some sort of game but Nintendo
going the standalone way with Mario
maker Peter are you excited to make your
own Mario levels oh hell yeah dude super
mario world has like a massive community
of people making custom variations of
the super nintendo original and so it's
just it's such a logical step for a
nintendo to do this I played some of the
HP last year and it's so easy to use and
you can just make stuff on the fly and
you know you say it comes without a game
I would be surprised if it didn't come
with the the base games that are
available to pull from okay with in here
already to give you a template to modify
like what better way to take your
favorite level from an old mario game
and tweak it you know you got to start
somewhere and i think that's a great
place to start and they got around and
how about a crossover Shin Megami Tensei
X fire album guy alexa ray corriea Tommy
that's my m.o I they went quiet on that
game for a couple years and then they
reintroduced it a couple months ago I
they're saying it's going to come out
this year so I'm betting we're gonna get
some hands-on we have to if it's coming
out this year and anything else in the
world of Fire Emblem news there is the
3ds game they've been slowly trickling
or releasing a trickle of information
for that over the past couple months as
well again I hope that we get hands-on
crossing my fingers since it's early
2016 here I think it's
wait 2015 across the ocean in native
Japan but I'm betting we'll get hands-on
cool and there's a bunch more games on
this list some of whom are ones we have
not heard very much Oh project treasure
yes was though this was like first
teased to feel like with it this year
earlier this year was a dirty leg
directed yeah direct this year and then
we saw it again not during this direct
because it was there was maybe a little
bit violent for for a noble directly go
and watch them from trailers for project
return it looks kind of cool it's like a
lira Croft Tomb Raider style game but
multiplayer and on Wii U which is not
something you normally see ya hear me by
Bandai Namco it mixes like the
characters that I saw on the YouTube
video took characters and ideas like a
lot of different cut corners of like
fantasy and sci-fi kind of mix them
together and yeah it's like a four
player dungeon crawler maybe we play but
I think yeah I believe they said this
it'll be a free-to-play game whoa he
knows at Kirby's Epic Yarn was a super
cool looking game super fluffy ass
looking game Yoshi's woolly world man
they seem to have stuck themselves to
some sort of weird new trend about
making games about fabric has anyone
seen much of this Bob way it looks so
good you haven't seen a lot we played
some of it last year how do you three
yeah are they yeah I enjoyed it it's
very much oh she you know so the sore
the thing that to worry about what this
is the same thing I think that kind of
hurt Kirby in the canvas curse is that
is amazing as this game looks when
you're looking at on your TV if you have
to play while looking at your screen is
it loving the gamepad like that'll
that'll hurt it a little bit but it
seems like the gameplay in this lends
itself more to like playing like a
normal game looking your screen and
getting to actually enjoy the really
crazy texture he's pooping yarn ball at
one of the best things about owning
mario kart i think and wii u for me was
that they've kept releasing dlc for it
only I think it was only the last month
or a couple of weeks ago that the second
pack hey Matt and 200 cc yeah with
reverse courses well I didn't know that
they were gonna do that or rather they
flipped them sort of horizontally
instead of going back to front do you
think did we'll see more of this stuff
in Nintendo you think we'll see some
smash bros DLC or some mario kart DLC
we're going to get more smash bros
character yeah these games are platforms
now the stuff they're coming out with if
you look at splatoon for exam
pulled a game like if there's a lot to
do but there's not a lot of variety in
what you get to do like you retread a
lot of the same ground with different
challenges but again it's like at the
perfect bed for new content to drop in
right they've already done that
yesterday with a new map a new weapon
and a new magic type I mean what better
way to sort of set the pace to do more
of that and I think we're going to see
you splatoon DLC announced and Mario
Kart like I don't think it would be
surprising for there to be another set
of tracks and a look at a racer yeah for
smash brothers we already you know they
did a call-out asking for who do you
want to see in the game I bet they
announce that it at e3 and before we
wrap up here Nintendo does a bunch of
stuff that we would like to maybe see
perhaps new Metroid new 3ds maybe a
price drop for the Wii U at one each
Justin for us what would you like to see
Nintendo do this is well something that
will never happen is bringing all those
awesome Dragon Quest games times that's
all I'm gonna say oh god yeah my heart
Dragon Quest or else is getting a
physical edition like I collect inner
dragon biscuit don't I I really want to
see the new 3d yes like a regular sized
version I'm not hopeful but I think you
know lacking any other hardware news
that's a good opportunity for Nintendo
to kind of just please audiences looking
for that kind of thing from intend oh
because games are great but hardware
always creates a certain buzz yeah so
I'm we'll see I also my guess we'll know
in two weeks time and we'll have all the
news on gamespot com will have all the
e3 nonsense happening there between news
trailers and our live show of course
over the set of three days on the show
floor itself and everything starting on
the sunday from Bethesda's crazy
conference as well so make sure you
stick to gamespot com the week of e3